the United States is at risk of another
big covid surge because so many people
have completely moved on from covid and
there is a new variant that can
significantly evade not only vaccines
but prior infection this continues to be
a story with many people on dramatically
different sides there are some who for
months and months and months have been
saying the massive surge is coming and
fortunately it has not you look at cases
and deaths now particularly compared to
a year ago very very low on the other
hand the issue is well there may not
have been a significant flu season surge
yet but our confidence is going to lead
to a massive spike in Coven what do you
still do today when it comes to trying
to prevent getting sick if anything I'd
be curious to hear from folks in the
comments do you still think about covid
have you moved on is that smart is it
imprudent let me know what you think